first I want to talk about one of my
many best features creativity it's the
skill that allowed me to claim a taxable
income last year of negative 48 dollars
now everyone knows conservatives have a
monopoly on creativity while people on
the Left are historically very uncreated
it's a it's a scientific fact that the
left brain controls math whining and
sadness while the right controls
creativity horsepower and flexing and
for concrete evidence of conservative
creativity look no further than the
response to last week's deadly shooting
at a Santa Fe Texas High School now this
is America's 23rd school shooting so far
this year and the unimaginative liberals
are singing the same old - we have more
lacks gun control in this country and
that's why we're having more shootings
easy availability of guns guns guns guns
guns guns guns guns saying something
over and over again doesn't make it true
hashtag no collision but while the left
can only think of one answer the
creative right has come up with so many
different things to blame for our school
shootings abortions video games trench
coats ritalin violent media doors and
according to NRA board member ted nugent
unhealthy diets yes I mean Ted knows the
real threat is junk food I mean who can
forget that iconic scene from The Deer
Hunter where they spin a can of monster
energy ballers blends and then just chug
it
but don't just listen to Ted take it
from a guy who's always on the right
side of history
brand-new NRA president Oliver North he
knows what's causing these shootings
we're trying like the dickens to treat
the symptom without treating the disease
and the disease in this case isn't the
Second Amendment
the disease is youngsters who are
steeped in a culture of violence yes see
no one knows about a culture of violence
like Oliver North the guy is literally
an
animated character in and a paid
consultant for call of duty black ops 2
yeah and I'm sure in level 3 his
character takes the time to explain to
the kids playing why violence is so
wrong but the free thinking
conservatives didn't stop there
uber creative Tennessee representative
Diane Black has an inspired explanation
for the shooting that she told a group
of pastors last week
[Music]
yes yes it's available the root cause of
shootings is disgusting hi shel grocery
store porn and that's not even
considering all the store brand porn on
the bottom shelf just thank God no one
tells kids about the Internet so thank
God as well for the Conservatives are
pointing to all the right causes of
school shootings porno ritalin trench
coats the media unhealthy food
videogames doors I mean if you step back
and look at what all of those
explanations really add up to I mean the
real threat to our kids has never been
more clear
[Applause]